uh hi I'm mark Gagliardi and today we're
gonna talk about Robert smalls when
Robert smalls was 12 years old his
father Henry McKee the plantation owner
was like listen my son then I'm not
allowed to tell anybody is when I sent
but really or my son
you are special er than the other slaves
but you keep getting in trouble we think
that the best thing for you right now is
if we send you to Charleston and Robert
smells is like oh I'm sorry you're my
slave owner and you're gonna send me to
Charleston where I can learn an actual
business trade yeah that sounds like a
good idea and he spent seven years being
a crewman on board all of these
different vessels that traveled around
these Charleston waterways including the
Confederate ship the planter at this
point the Civil War has broken out the
officers so they turned to Robert smalls
and they were like listen man don't tell
anyone we're gonna go on shore keep an
eye on the ship while we're goin
Robert smells like sure man I've got
this you don't have to worry about me
and Robert smalls thought to himself
these guys just want to go get some
hookers these two other guys who aren't
the guys getting hookers also went to
get hookers I basically have this ship
to myself he says hey man this is the
perfect opportunity for us to steal this
ship and get over to the
Union side here's what I want you to do
go get my family and go round up the
families of the other two seamen of this
vessel and I will bring all of us to
freedom
mark you remember at the beginning of
this you said you were not going to
promise yours I really only sold today
and what happened probably this of
fighting here I come cue eye of the
tiger
all right I only do this in honor of
Robert smalls ah god damn it what are we
talking about once Robert smalls had
taken control of the ship
smalls thought to himself I'm still
going to have to make it past five
Confederate forts
luckily I look enough like the captain
when I wear the hat and this jacket and
I have the Confederate codebook which
means I know what signals to throw up in
order to get us through the harbor so
Robert smalls is piloting the ship past
Confederate troops so he got first
nerves like to toot toot and they
thought there's a white guy trying to
pass through let's just wave at him and
he made it through oh all right
so he made it through five Confederate
signals all the way through to the gates
of Fort Sumter not only did a guy at the
Fort Sumter say all right let's let the
planter through the guard at Fort Sumter
said hey you go kill yourselves a couple
of Yankees
[Music]
and it was only at dawn that the
Confederates realized hey maybe this
isn't quite on the level and they start
lobbing cannon fire and as he is
barreling towards Union forces he thinks
oh my god I've got to do something to
make sure that these Union forces don't
think that I am coming to confront them
are we gonna do this thing from the
floor man really I want you to be
comfortable so we'll do wherever I'll do
it from the floor as he is barreling
towards these Union forces smalls turns
to his wife and says I told you to bring
a bed sheet did you bring a bed sheet
she's like honey I brought us a bread
sheet hey Mark let's just have some
water just take a quick break in this
drink some water are we getting in a
fight no no why was your okay what do
you want to know baby the next part
he hoists of the sheet as a white flag
of surrender he pulls up to the USS
onward and says hey man I hung I hear
uncle Abe could use a transport ship
this was a big deal in Lincoln say all
right man that's great here's $1,500 hey
here's a quick question do you think
that you could get some Union guys like
some some some celebrity some
celebrities
wonder what's the word I'm looking for
some celebrated what's the word I'm
looking for some mark right hold on not
celebrities some soldiers he was the
first to enlist 5000 blacks in the Union
Army so at the end of the American Civil
War civil were sorting the color same
kids watched a live audition and he had
just enough money what not only did
Robert smalls steal a boat and
get his freedom not only these are five
terms as a US congressman after the war
Robert smalls went into South Carolina
and said hey see that house over there
that's the house I want to buy which
house that one I'm gonna buy them the
key house
the last time that he was in that house
he was owned by another person this time
rather own the house hmm Robert smalls
yeah man you like him I love
[Music]